Je ne suis pas du tout d'accord avec cette idée,
avec cette définition de la nature,
parce que nous sommes fondamentalement des animaux.
Nous avons évolué sur cette planète
ensemble avec d'autres animaux, avec qui nous avons partagé la planète,
avec toutes les plantes et avec tous les microbes.
Je pense donc que la nature n'est pas
indépendante de l'humanité, homme et femme.
Je pense que la nature se trouve partout où il y a de la vie,
là où plusieurs espèces vivent ensemble,
n'importe où l'on trouve du vert et du bleu, où la vie prospère et grandit.
Sous cette définition,
les choses prennent une forme différente.
Alors, je comprends qu'il y a certains aspects de cette nature
qui nous parlent d'une manière particulière.
Des endroits comme Yellowstone,
la steppe de Mongolie,
la Grande barrière de corail
ou le parc du Serengeti.
Des endroits que nous considérons comme étant des représentations édéniques
de la nature avant que nous ne la détruisions.
D'une certaine manière, ils ont été préservés de nos activités quotidiennes.
Beaucoup de ces lieux n'ont pas de route ou très peu,
et ainsi de suite.
Mais au fond, même ces lieux sont profondément influencés par l'Homme.
Prenons l'Amérique du Nord, par exemple,
puisque nous y sommes.
Il y a 15 000 ans, quand les premiers humains sont arrivés ici,
ils ont commencé à interagir avec la nature,
ce qui a mené à l'extinction de nombreux grands animaux,
du mastodonte au paresseux géant,
les tigres à dents de sabre,
tous ces animaux cools qui n'existent plus aujourd'hui.
Et quand ils ont disparu,
les écosystèmes ne se sont pas arrêtés.
D'énormes effets de ricochet ont changé les prairies en forêts,
ont changé la composition des forêts, arbre par arbre.
Alors, même dans ces paradis,
même dans ces endroits parfaits,
qui nous font penser à une époque où il n'y avait pas d'humains,
en fait, nous regardons un paysage humanisé.
Pas que des hommes préhistoriques, mais des hommes historiques, autochtones
présents jusqu'à l'arrivée des premiers colonisateurs.
Et cela vaut aussi pour les autres continents.
L'Homme est impliqué dans la nature
de manière très profonde depuis très longtemps.
Récemment, quelqu'un m'a dit :
« Il reste toujours des lieux sauvages. »
J'ai répondu : « Où ça ? Je veux y aller. »
Il a dit : « L'Amazone ! »
J'ai pensé : « Ah, l'Amazone ! J'en reviens. »
National Geographic m'a envoyée à Manú National Park,
qui se trouve au Pérou,
c'est un gros morceau de forêt tropicale en friche,
protégé en tant que parc national,
l'un des parcs les plus riches en nature au monde.
Et quand je suis arrivée en canoë, qu'ai-je trouvé ? Des gens.
Des gens qui y ont vécu pendant des centaines et des milliers d'années.
Ils vivent là et ne surnagent pas seulement au dessus la jungle.
Ils ont une relation profonde avec la nature.
Ils chassent. Ils cultivent.
Ils domestiquent les plantes.
Ils utilisent les ressources naturelles pour construire
et couvrir leurs maisons.
Ils apprivoisent même des animaux que nous considérions sauvages.
Ces gens sont là
et ils interagissent avec l'environnement de manière profonde,
et on peut le voir in situ.
J'étais avec un anthropologue durant le voyage
et il m'a dit en naviguant sur la rivière :
« Il n'y a pas de vide démographique dans l'Amazone. »
Cette affirmation m'a vraiment marquée,
car ça veut dire que l'Amazone tout entière est comme ça.
Il y a des gens partout.
Bien d'autres forêts tropicales sont pareilles,
mais pas seulement.
Par le passé, les gens ont influencé les écosystèmes
et ils continuent de le faire.
même dans les lieux où ils ne sont pas aussi visibles.
Alors, si toutes les définitions de la nature que l'on utilise
impliquent qu'elle est vierge
ou inhabitée,
si cela nous amène à conclure qu'il n'y a plus de nature,
alors, peut-être que ces définitions sont mauvaises.
Peut-être qu'on devrait la définir par la présence de plusieurs espèces,
par la présence de vie en plein essor.
Pris comme ça,
qu'obtient-on ?
Eh bien, c'est comme un miracle.
Soudain, la nature est tout autour de nous.
Soudain, on voit cette chenille de l'espèce des monarques
butiner sur cette plante
et on prend conscience de sa présence,
dans ce terrain vague à Chattanooga.
Regardez ce terrain vague.
Je veux dire, il y a probablement
au moins une douzaine d'espèces végétales qui y poussent
et qui permettent à plein d'insectes de vivre,
c'est un espace non entretenu, complètement sauvage.
C'est un genre de nature sauvage juste sous notre nez,
qu'on ne remarque même pas.
Il y a aussi un petit paradoxe intéressant.
Cette nature,
cet enclos sauvage et négligé
de notre vie urbaine, banlieusarde, agricole
qui passe sous notre radar,
on peut dire que c'est encore plus sauvage qu'un parc national,
parce que ces parcs sont attentivement gérés
au XXIe siècle.
Le Crater Lake dans le sud de l'Oregon, le parc le plus proche de chez moi,
est un bon exemple de paysage semblant venir du passé.
Mais ils le gèrent attentivement.
Leur problème en ce moment, c'est l'extinction du pin blanc.
Le pin blanc est beau, remarquable,
je dirais que c'est une large flore remarquable
qui pousse en haute altitude,
en ce moment, ils ont beaucoup de problèmes liés à une maladie.
Une rouille vésiculeuse est arrivée,
la scolyte.
Pour traiter ce problème, le service du parc a commencé à planter
des graines résistantes à la rouille dans le parc
même dans les régions sauvages.
Ils mettent même des anti-scolytes dans les zones clés
comme j'ai pu le voir, la dernière fois.
Ce genre de mesure est bien plus courant que vous ne le pensez.
Les parcs sont gérés minutieusement,
la faune et la flore sont maintenues à une certaine taille.
Les incendies sont contrôlés,
voire déclenchés.
Les espèces allogènes sont retirées
et les natives sont réintroduites.
En fait, j'ai vérifié,
le parc national de Banff fait exactement la même chose :
contrôler et déclencher les feux,
surveiller les loups, réintroduire les bisons.
Il faut beaucoup de travail pour que ces endroits aient l'air naturels.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Ce qu'il y a d'ironique, c'est que les lieux que l'on aime le plus
sont les endroits que l'on aime un peu trop, parfois.
Beaucoup aiment y aller
et parce qu'on fait en sorte qu’ils soient stables
malgré le monde qui change,
ils se fragilisent peu à peu au fil du temps.
Ce qui veut dire que ce sont les pires lieux
pour emmener nos enfants en vacances,
parce qu'on ne peut rien y faire.
On ne peut pas grimper aux arbres,
ni pêcher,
on ne peut pas faire un feu de camp n'importe où,
ni même ramener des pommes de pin.
Il y a tant de règles et de restrictions,
que pour un enfant,
c'est la nature la plus pénible qui soit.
Car les enfants n'aiment pas faire de randonnées
dans un lieu magnifique pendant 5 heures
pour ensuite avoir une vue magnifique.
On le recherche peut-être, nous,
mais les enfants veulent juste s'accroupir à un endroit
et bricoler là, voir comment c'est,
juste ramasser des trucs, construire une maison ou un château, ces choses-là.
Par ailleurs, ce genre d'endroits édéniques
sont généralement éloignés de là où les gens vivent,
C'est cher d'y aller. C'est dur de les visiter.
Ça veut dire que ce n'est que pour les élites
et c'est vraiment un problème.
The Nature Conservancy a mené une enquête auprès des jeunes
et leur a demandé combien de temps ils passaient dehors,
seulement 2 sur 5 passaient du temps dehors
plus d'une fois par semaine.
Les trois autres restaient à la maison.
Quand on leur demandait pourquoi, qu'est-ce qui les retenait,
la réponse dans 61 % des cas était :
« Il n'y a pas de zones naturelles près de chez moi. »
C'est dingue et c'est absolument faux,
71 % des gens aux États-Unis
vivent à moins de 10 minutes à pied d'un parc urbain.
Les chiffres sont sûrement similaires dans les autres pays.
Et c'est sans compter votre jardin,
les ruisseaux et les terrains vagues.
Tout le monde habite près de la nature.
Tous les enfants habitent près de la nature.
On a simplement oublié comment la percevoir.
On passe trop de temps à regarder les reportages de David Attenborough
où la nature est vraiment sexy.
(Rires)
Et on a oublié comment apprécier la nature qui se trouve juste à notre porte,
la nature des arbres dans la rue.
Par exemple, à Philadelphie,
il y a cette superbe voie ferrée surélevée,
que l'on peut voir du sol, qui a été abandonnée.
Ça pourrait nous faire penser aux débuts de High Line à Manhattan,
c'est semblable, mais ils ne l'ont pas encore transformée en parc,
bien que ce soit un projet.
Pour l'instant, c'est une sorte de petite étendue sauvage secrète,
au cœur de Philadelphie,
et si vous savez où se trouve le trou dans le grillage,
vous pouvez escalader jusqu'au sommet
et trouver cette prairie complètement sauvage,
flottant au-dessus de la ville.
Et toutes ces plantes proviennent d'une graine,
arrivée là par elle-même.
C'est une nature totalement indépendante et obstinée.
Et c'est en plein milieu de la ville.
Ils ont envoyé des gens pour faire des enquêtes biologiques
et il y a plus de 50 espèces végétales là-bas.
Pas seulement des plantes.
C'est un écosystème fonctionnel.
Il crée de la terre, il isole le carbone.
La pollinisation s'y produit.
C'est réellement un écosystème.
Les scientifiques ont commencé à utiliser le terme de « nouveaux écosystèmes »,
car ils sont souvent dominés par les espèces allogènes
et car ils sont vraiment bizarres.
Ils ne ressemblent à rien de ce que l'on connaît.
Longtemps, on a ignoré tous ces nouveaux écosystèmes.
On parle de champs agricoles qui ont repoussé,
de plantations de bois qui ne sont pas gérées quotidiennement,
des forêts de seconde venue en général, toute la côte est,
où, après que les cultures sont parties vers l'ouest, les forêts ont surgi.
Et bien sûr, presque tout Hawaï
où les nouveaux écosystèmes sont la norme,
où les espèces exotiques dominent complètement.
Cette forêt-ci a de l'érable de Queensland,
des fougères venant d'Asie du sud-est.
On peut faire son propre nouvel écosystème.
C'est très simple :
arrêtez de tondre votre pelouse.
(Rires)
L'écologiste Ilkka Hanski a fait cette expérience.
Il a arrêté de tondre sa pelouse et après quelques années,
il a fait venir ses étudiants, qui ont fait un bio-blitz dans son jardin
et ils ont trouvé 375 espèces végétales,
dont deux espèces en voie d'extinction.
Alors, quand vous êtes sur la future High Line à Philadelphie,
entouré par cette nature sauvage,
entouré par cette diversité, cette abondance, ce rayonnement,
vous pouvez regarder à côté
et voir le terrain de jeu d'une école locale
qui ressemble à ça.
Ces enfants ont ça...
Selon ma définition,
il y a beaucoup de nature sur la planète,
mais ce lieu-là n'en ferait pas partie.
Il n'y a que des êtres humains, aucune plante, aucun animal.
Et ce que j'aurais voulu faire, c'est installer une échelle
pour que ces enfants puissent venir dans cette super prairie avec moi.
Je crois que c'est un peu le choix auquel on doit faire face.
Si on pense que ces nouvelles natures n'ont pas de valeur,
autant les recouvrir de pavés.
Et dans un monde qui change,
il faut être prudent avec notre définition de la nature.
Afin de ne pas la voler à nos enfants,
on doit faire deux choses.
D'abord, on ne peut pas définir la nature comme tout ce qui est intact.
Ça n'a jamais eu de sens.
La nature n'est plus intacte depuis des milliers d'années.
Ça exclut la majorité de la nature que les gens peuvent visiter
et avec laquelle se connecter,
y compris la seule nature que les enfants ne peuvent pas toucher.
Ce qui m'amène à la deuxième chose à faire :
laissons les enfants toucher la nature,
tout ce qui n'est pas touché est délaissé.
(Applaudissements)
On fait face à de sévères problèmes environnementaux sur cette planète.
Le changement climatique entre autres.
Il y en a d'autres : la perte d'habitat, la chose qui m'empêche le plus de dormir.
Mais pour les résoudre,
on a besoin de gens intelligents et dévoués
qui se préoccupent de la nature.
Et la seule façon d'élever une génération
qui se préoccupe la nature
est de la laisser être en contact avec elle.
J'ai une « théorie des cabanes » sur l'écologie et sur la préservation.
Tous les écologistes et les biologistes que je connais,
tous les restaurateurs que je connais,
ont construit des cabanes quand ils étaient enfants.
Avec une génération qui ne sait pas construire une cabane,
on aura une génération ne sachant pas s'intéresser à la nature.
Je ne veux pas être celle qui dira à cet enfant issu d'un programme spécial
qui emmène les enfants pauvres de Philadelphie
dans les parcs de la ville,
je ne veux pas être celle qui lui dira
que la fleur qu'il a dans la main est une mauvaise herbe qu'il faut jeter.
Je préférerais plutôt apprendre de ce garçon
que peu importe l'origine de cette plante,
elle est belle et elle mérite d'être appréciée.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)